[Musique]
nous allons vous conter l'histoire les
inventer des aventures
aventures de renard
[Musique]
leroy noble
un des paiements des renards magasin
pourquoi regarder des sports les
agissements de renards ont fini par
décider ysengrin le lot a demandé
justice auprès du noble lyon
leroy mandate aussitôt brin l'ours au
château de maupertuis afin de
réprimander renard
oh
[Musique]
on
ona je suis mais sachez du roi
forte et écouter son message au brun
vous n'auriez pas dû prendre cette peine
inutile
j'allais me rendre à la cour du roi dès
que j'aurai eu manger les excellents
mais que dame hermeline à préparer pour
moi un accusé ne doit-il pas prendre des
forces avant d'affronter la justice
j'ai dont ce matin passé en revue mais
provision de poids et de l'art et j'ai
déjeuné de plusieurs rayons d'un
excellent miel comment vous savez où se
procurait du miel ah ben si j'étais sûr
de trouver en vous un véritable ami je
vous donnerai autant de cet excellent
miel que vous pourriez en désirer il
n'aime pas bien loin
juste à l'entrée du bois gardés par le
forestier lanfroy mais ne venez-vous pas
ici un ennemi
assurément non horrible si peu confiance
en moi que craignez-vous jeu sert leroy
bien sûr mais je ne serai jamais dit
loyal bien
[Musique]
voilà ce que je vous ai promis la
réserve de miel est ici rentrer la tête
et prenez ce que vous voulez nous iront
boire ensuite
[Musique]
alors si au bras comment trouvez-vous
mon miel comme vous restez l'autre
voulez-vous tout garder pour vous sans
m'en laisser
[Musique]
allô allô que nous le vent la pluie
une
[Musique]
oh